evil Trump strikes again shocking images
of immigrant children sleeping in cages
on the floor and of course a former LA
mayor at Obama flak key journalists all
blame heartless Trump but not so fast
everyone turns out these pictures were
four years old when their hero Obama was
in charge and with that the loud condom
nations go silent who cares now since
their Idol was boss at the time but
there's more this photo of an all baby
seats immigration detention bus was also
shared and blamed on Trump one-acre
called it a prison bus just for babies
but the photo was also from Obama's era
and it's a bus for field trips and did
you hear the widely shared claim about
1500 immigrant kids that were separated
from mom and dad again by evil Trump why
these children actually arrived alone
- their parents and then were placed
among sponsors the government had lost
track of them which says something about
the system the system that Trump
actually wants to fix and so as Trump
cements his agenda through significant
legislation these folks have the vapors
over imaginary discrimination but if you
can't blame him for that
what's next Ebola malaria your lousy
love life and they accused Trump of
spreading baloney the media can't even
check the date on a photo and that's
their job to check facts it's all the
usual suspects identity activists the
paranoids and pajamas you know the New
York Times fake news is now no longer a
catchphrase it's a brand I have an idea
Dana where is it
shoot I wear Beautiful Mind notes so
many yeah Trump should join national TV
and lay out point by point his daca plan
to embarrass the Democrats with the fact
that he is actually offering a plan to
citizenship that they don't but don't do
it on tweets go out there and do it
that's a good idea
I absolutely think that he could do a
lot more policy oriented speeches and
that would drive news for like 48 hours
just like that and nothing else yeah
there's like Drive on that news he could
do an oval office address it would be
one way to do it that really focuses the
mind that means that it would be a prime
time address if this is the number one
issue certainly for a Republican
but if it's an economic issue for care
about also in June you have all the
Democrats in the house and a lot of
House Republicans signing this discharge
petition to actually force boats on the
docket issue so the president I think
would be right to get out in front of it
that's a that's a great idea Gregg thank
you in the meantime the other thing you
should do is to say I'm not going to
wait for Congress to fix this issue if
whatever he can do to fix the system as
it currently stands within the federal
government about keeping track of these
children he could lay that out too yeah
you know Jesse I don't know if you saw
this over the weekend because you unlike
me have a life CNN did a piece on
whether it was right for Ivanka Trump to
tweet a photo of her and her son did you
see that she had a picture of her in her
son because they thought it was like
while this missing child narrative is
going on how bad is it that she's
showing a picture of her kid what is up
with CNN I don't know I don't think they
know what's up with themselves but I
didn't really look at the blackberry a
lot or iPhone this weekend I try to
unfold I didn't and then every time I
did dial in and check it out the media
was screwing up every single time
whether it was Ivanka or this and I was
listening to Limbaugh which was a lot of
fun Marie on the drive back talking
about this story about the photos and he
had a great lot he said the Democrats
keep getting hit square between the eyes
and they don't even realize it and think
about it you have this you have the
Russia investigation you have the
kneeling you have the opposing the tax
cuts everything keeps backfiring on the
Democrats but the sad thing is is that
this photo goes out thousands tens of
thousands of times and then the
retraction and the deletion doesn't get
seen so the damages are yeah but the
reason they do this the reason they have
the policy to separate Children and
Families is to discourage human
trafficking to discourage families from
taking kids across a treacherous hot
dangerous southern border trip and they
want to discourage dangerous and illegal
immigration so if they want to change
the policy let's get a deal on daca
let's go on merit-based and they can
hammer it out but if you're just gonna
take a potshot you're gonna embarrass
yourself they also try to separate them
so because the adults go to
that you wouldn't want to have children
and find a different some would say it's
a more humane policy to do that that's
the argument a lot of these kids that
show up with no parents and then you
have to decide what to do with them and
that's where you play placing my
sponsors like you would foster care
right Murray do you think that one of
the larger problems here that's been
going on for two years is there is so
much emotional baggage about Trump from
the Democrats that they they can't so
would so their confirmation bias forces
them to just see everything like it's
got to be his fault it's got to be his
fault and they haven't yet been able to
shake that well I think you could say
the same about conservatives and Barack
Obama or Hillary Clinton right we're all
on opposing sides they're both people
you know right I've heard that because I
don't listen to Limbaugh sorry your loss
here's here's the thing though on the
immigration issue itself it is
incredibly emotional because these are
real people's lives and as Jesse just
mentioned there are very dangerous
conditions when you have unaccompanied
minors showing up at the border this is
a heartbreaking situation so I think
that part of the challenge is both sides
have gone to such extremes now that the
space for a deal on daca or on any of
this is increasingly shrinking
especially in a midterm year if
President Trump went out and gave an
address that was somewhere down the
middle that had a daca fix but got some
border security and tried to bring both
sides together I depending on what it
said would probably think that's a good
idea
the challenge is the Republican Congress
isn't on the same page particularly in
the house particularly in a midterm year
so now we're in a situation where the
Trump administration has separated 800
children from their parents since
October fort often good reasons
sometimes not and what do we do now
where are these 1500 children this is
heartbreaking and no one in this
political climate it seems like is
trying to actually order by the
administration you should be a sponsor I
volunteer you watch for me yeah really
last word what are you people are
exposed as wrong they never admit it
they just removed their tweets and run
away and that drives me nuts
yeah you can't stand to you're keeping
track yet expensive in
but yeah but it's true you see the
mainstream media making these mistakes
and they chase after the accounts and
they're putting up false stories I mean
how glaring is this as its photographs
from 2014 we talked about just really
backfiring everyone should care whatever
your politics administration and about
children but when you look at the actual
facts of the laws here that President
Trump his administration is following
the laws on the books in terms of what
you do when people enter the country
illegally with children the goal and aim
behind it is to be protective of
children so it doesn't foster this whole
legal atmosphere of human trafficking
etc and flat-out follow the law don't
into the country illegally put yourself
and your children at jeopardy that's not
love that's foolish illegal desperation
in terms of not honoring and following
the laws other people are following in
trying to get into this country legally
it's a nation of immigrants we embrace
and encourage people to apply for legal
citizenship but we have the capacity to
house about 3,000 you know family so how
is this going from what a bad situation
to a worse situation it's certainly not
acting in the best interest of welfare
of your children to do so and we shall
leave it there I never thought I'd say
that all right